herzlich willkommen zurück zu einem
weiteren die richtigen fragen spezial
nach lars klingbeil dem spd-chef jetzt
mit dem fdp-fraktionschef christian dürr
hamas hätte ja wir hören dass 20
mitglieder ihrer fraktion gegen die
impfpflicht stimmen wollen sind die in
wahrheit die einzigen die bei ihnen
ehrlich sind weil vor ein paar wochen
hätten sie wahrscheinlich auch noch
gesagt ich bin gegen geben vielleicht ja
vor einem halben jahr hat ja jede
deutschen partei gesagt wir wollen keine
impfpflicht deswegen haben wir uns ja
gemeinsam auf ein anderes verfahren
verabredet es wird gruppenanträge geben
das heißt ja dass fraktionsübergreifend
diskutiert werden wird nicht entlang der
parteigrenzen sondern werden sich
verschiedene gruppen zusammenfinden die
einen sagen gegen die impfpflicht die
anhalt werden sagen dafür ist wird
mittel wege geben da gibt's ja nicht nur
schwarz und weiß und ich glaube das ist
bei so einer wichtigen medizinischen
debatte auch genau richtig nicht
parteipolitik sondern die sache im fokus
und deswegen ist die richtige strategie
über die debatte über die impfpflicht
erscheint besonders absurd aufgrund
dessen will jetzt gehört haben dass
nicht genügend impfstoff gibt also warum
diskutiert die fdp überhaupt diese im
pflicht wenn wir nicht genügend booster
material die fdp diskutiert ja nicht
allein um gottes willen das ist ja eine
breite diskussion in deutschland schon
seit ein paar wochen aber sie haben
vollkommen recht wir haben unter
umständen zu wenig impfstoff ich bin
jetzt dankbar dem neuen
gesundheitsminister so dass er sich
schnell darum kümmert denn da ist ja
offensichtlich ein riesenfehler passiert
in der vergangenheit erst 12 wir haben
eine hohe bereitschaft also die sollte
man natürlich nutzen wir haben zurzeit
die erfolgreichste europäische booster
kampagne deswegen first things first
zunächst mal all diejenigen impfen zu
wollen und die debatte kommt dann
nächstes jahr aber die debatte ist ja da
sollte man jetzt nicht sagen wir beenden
die debatte über die impfpflicht und
fokussieren uns voll darauf dass es
genügend impfstoff ist beim thema
impfpflicht das hat ja auch entspannt
sehr frühzeitig richtig gesagt da geht
es um die frage wie man mittelfristig
die pandemie bekämpft kurzfristig müssen
wir jetzt alles schimpfen was geht
mittelfristig kann es sein dass es ohne
breiteste impfung gegebenenfalls sogar
wiederholt gar nicht geht deswegen ist
die debatte im kommenden jahr richtig
jetzt ist der fokus auf impfstoff und
die impfkampagne weiter warnt wie soll
wir dass am ende eine mehrheit in der
fdp fraktion sagt nein impfpflicht nicht
wir sind die partei der freiheit die
sorge habe ich nicht weil am ende des
tages ist nicht um fdp cdu csu spd grüne
oder linke geht sondern es geht darum
welche mehrheiten sich und die debatte
muss im bundestag geführt werden wäre ja
blöd wenn das halt wenn das nur über
ihre für stein will die partei der faber
die hälfte den ball schon wichtig das
ist richtig aber sie sind die partei der
freiheit in der korona debatte immer auf
freiheitsrechte gewählt das ist doch
völlig unglaubwürdig dass sie das jetzt
christian lindner sagen naja jetzt sind
wir eine regierung kommen soll es mit
impfpflicht kein problem den eso ist ja
nicht selber gesagt 20 leute sind zur
zeit dabei das zu überlegen es gibt
viele andere die was anderes überlegen
sind in der partei mlpd
492 abgeordnete insofern sieht man
ungefähr die mehrheitsverhältnisse zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt nichts desto trotz
wir müssen die impfkampagne jetzt
weiterführen darauf liegt auch der fokus
der bundesregierung und nebenbei gesagt
zum thema freiheitsrechte ja klar wir
haben ja ein anderes
infektionsschutzgesetz hart kritisiert
von der union jetzt zeigt sich ja das
ganze scheint zu funktionieren wir
müssen omikron abwarten das sage ich
dazu aber wir haben heute eine andere
situation keine schulschließung keine
flächen erschließung des einzelhandels
beispielsweise und keine ausgangssperren
vor einem jahr haben wir hier gestanden
und diskutiert dass menschen nachts
nicht gemeinsam spazieren gehen dürfen
aber danach ins gemeinsame schlafzimmer
also andere situationen die rechte
impfquote müssen sie müssen wir
erreichen damit die impfpflicht nicht
kommen ich befürchte das kann ihn ich
bin ja ökonomischen ökonom jetzt nicht
sagen sondern wahrscheinlich nicht mal
mediziner aber so hoch wie möglich und
vor einigen den jetzigen impfstoff
nutzen nicht auf neue impfstoffe warten
sondern jetzt erst mal hinten kann man
nur jedem raten das hilft gegen die
pandemie und schützt ein selbst wie
musik fotos und ich kann sie nicht sagen
ich kann es nicht sagen ich glaube dass
es sinnvoll ist so viel wie möglich und
jeden überzeugen und die bereitschaft
ist doch da da sind doch menschen jetzt
in schlangen stehen 100 meter an und das
müssen wir jetzt bedienen darauf liegt
unser fokus deswegen auch das thema
krisenstab dann muss das die logistik
vernünftig funktionieren es muss
impfstoff da sein impfbereitschaft
nutzen die deutschen sind bereit sich
impfen zu lassen ihre wähler beginnen
oder wir hören dass auch in den foren
sozusagen sind enttäuscht davon dass die
fdp gerade bei den corona freiheiten
jetzt zurücksteckt und den ganzen kurs
mitfährt was ist ihre antwort einer
woche sind wir heftigst kritisiert
worden dass wir das so gesagt haben
diese bundes notbremse all die dinge in
sich an die stimme aus bayern von herrn
söder der hat riesige krone raten und
hat trotzdem schlaue hinweise gegeben
nein das teile ich nicht wir haben ganz
viel freiheitsrechte halten zurück
erhalten auch und eins ist auch wahr zum
thema ins licht man muss ja
freiheitsrechte auch da gegeneinander
abwägen es gibt ja menschen die sind
eingeschränkt durch corona es gibt
menschen die brauchen eine operation die
sie zurzeit wegen der situation auf den
intensivstationen nicht bekommen können
und da ist es auch richtig so eine
öffentliche debatte zu führen welche
freiheitsrechte gerade wie eingeschränkt
sind jetzt hat die niedersachsen ein
gericht die 2g regel für den
einzelhandel gekippt zeigt das nicht
dass sie dazu hart vorgehen oder dass
die politik insgesamt zu hart vorgehen
im ganzen land niedersachsen große
koalition spd und cdu ich fand das
problematisch weil zweig kommt fast dran
an einen login für den einzelhandel und
deswegen ist es gut dass das
oberverwaltungsgericht in lüneburg das
anders entschieden hat zeigt auch immer
wieder dass der dass der rechtsstaat
funktioniert
der bund hat ja nichts zweig vorgegeben
sondern die haben einen gegendruck wahl
gehen wir haben einen instrumentenkasten
zur verfügung gestellt und wenn krasse
hotspot sind siehe bayern und sachsen
die das ja nicht im griff haben
offensichtlich auch die landesregierung
dort dann muss man anders reagieren als
beispielsweise in meinem heimatland
niedersachsen zweig im einzelhandel
zweig in den bars und restaurants ist
das das falsche mittel das beste mittel
ist sich impfen zu lassen dann kommen
wir auch von runter und deswegen ist ja
auch diese poster kampagne so wichtig
weil wir wissen dass bietet den echten
impfschutz also je mehr wir impfen desto
weniger freiheitseinschränkung und noch
mal ich finde es vollkommen
nachvollziehbar dass das gericht das
dort gekippt hat war eine entscheidung
der hannoverschen großen koalition ich
hätte anders gesehen aber da müssen auch
landesregierung entscheiden können und
dann für ihre entscheidungen
geradestehen große debatte ist die frage
wie man künftig mit denjenigen umgehen
soll die auf die straße gehen die gegen
korona regeln demonstrieren aber nur
unter ist eben auch extremisten gibt die
fackel aufmärsche machen wie kann ich
eigentlich als jemand der sagt ich bin
gegen die impfpflicht ich bin gegen
bestimmte regeln meine rechte wahrnehmen
und auf die straße gehen wir nicht davon
ausgehen muss dass ich dann als corona
ihrer schimpft werde also jeder kann auf
die straße gehen und mir ist es wichtig
zu sagen
99,9 prozent der menschen in deutschland
gehen nicht mit fackeln vor die häuser
von politikern und sprechen
morddrohungen aus und da wo sowas
passiert muss der rechtsstaat tätig
werden ist doch keine frage was in
sachsen da passiert ist es unerträglich
darf auch nicht passieren weil sonst
können politiker auch nicht mehr frei
sprechen und die meinungs- bühne wird
einfach kleiner nichtsdestotrotz es ist
vollkommen legitim auch gegen korona
maßnahmen zu demonstrieren oder gegen zu
sein das kurze demokratie dazu aber das
grafikkarten sind nicht hinaus sehen sie
auch das problem dass man das gefühl hat
wenn man auf diese demonstration schaut
das ist ja schwer ist als jemand der
jetzt einfach ganz vernünftig sagen und
ich bin dagegen
da in einen topf geschmissen wird weil
am ende wird man sagen begrüßt aber ja
mit rechtsextremen oder mit den
extremisten auf die straße sie haben ja
gerade teile meiner fraktion erwähnt 20
von 92 abgeordneten gesagt wir sind bei
einer impfpflicht skeptisch ja keine
extremisten sondern ganz im gegenteil
hoch angesehene politiker natürlich ist
diese debatte legitim findet mitten im
deutschen bundestag statt und auch da
sage ich unterschied zu einem jahr da
gab es ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
nachts um 2 uhr die hefte tschuldigung
für die wortwahl candy quatsch gespielt
alles hinter verschlossener tür jetzt
auf offener bühne im bundestag auch das
ist ein wert die debatte ist vollkommen
in ordnung dagegen zu sein an der einen
stelle dafür an anderer stelle total
legitim straftaten sind nicht in ordnung
debatte ebenfalls darum was man mit
diensten wie telegramm macht was mit
hass im netz ist was kann man da tun
sollte telegramm irgendwie gesperrt
werden naja da müssen straftaten
verfolgt werden also weder morddrohungen
auf ausspricht dass eine straftat in
deutschland da ist auch der rechtsstaat
gefordert die landespolizei behörden
ermitteln müssen und das hat ja an die
bundesländern wir hatten auch kollegen
die da bedroht worden sind das hat auch
funktioniert also da gucken auch die
sicherheitsbehörden rein da brauchen
jetzt keine keine verbote allgemeinen
aussprechen sondern muss in diese
netzwerke reingucken um in straftaten
passieren kommt der rechtsstaat wird
tätig zum abschluss der tür große
debatte in der ganzen welt was passiert
der ukraine was passiert mit russland
jetzt gab es ein gerichtsurteil das im
zuge des tiergartens von
staatsterrorismus gesprochen hat ist es
jetzt nicht endgültig an der zeit zu
sagen nord stream 2 das war's also bei 7
242 situationen einmal die rechtliche
dimension da geht es um
genehmigungsverfahren das macht die
bundesnetzagentur in deutschland und die
andere frage ist natürlich auch eine
politische ich fand das was der
europäische rat gestern beschlossen hat
vollkommen richtig sehr deutlich zu
sagen russland bis hierhin und nicht
weiter so geht es nicht und wir haben ja
wir sind
hier sind die europäische union
viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt
nicht sinnvoll ist jetzt option zu
jobben um sie dann wieder zurückzuziehen
sondern sehr klar den russen zu sagen so
geht es nicht und dann auch h tätig zu
werden aber im europäischen konzert also
nicht einzelne stimmen weil sonst spielt
russland uns gleich nochmal sie
eventuell weiter ein fachgeschäft mit
staatsterroristen wir machen keine
geschäfte mit starts jurist angehalten
weil die haben versucht über ein
konstrukt in den europäischen
energiemarkt zu kommen der rechtswidrig
ist zum jetzigen zeitpunkt und deswegen
ist es zwei zurzeit auch nicht genehmigt
zum abschluss viele unserer
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer unser leser
machen sich sorgen wie es mit der
inflation weiter gehen im neuen jahr was
kann man dagegen tun als ich das thema
vom 34 aufgetan hat bin ich noch
angeguckt worden wir haben das auto also
das ist eine ganz ganz relevante debatte
und jetzt auch das was die ezb gesagt
hat für die inflation im kommenden jahr
macht mir auch sorgen ein grund mehr
dass wir als politik versuchen die
preise zu reduzieren wir werden
beispielsweise die eeg-umlage
vollständig abschaffen das heißt diese
zusätzlichen staatskosten auf den
strompreis reduzieren das was die ampel
tun kann tut sie bereits und die beste
der beste hinweis ist für die
europäischen staaten sich nicht noch
mehr zu verschulden damit beim thema
zinsen die ezb nicht so zurückhaltend
sein muss um die inflation zu bekämpfen
thema schulden haben sich verzockt bei
der wahl des ministeriums dass sie jetzt
im finanzministerium haben und einen
rekord nachtragshaushalt verabschieden
müssen eben gegenteil wir reduzieren
gerade den haftungsrahmen um 300
milliarden euro des bundes wir
reduzieren direkte kredite um 50
milliarden euro also wir tun alles dafür
um den das geld der steuerzahler dreimal
mindestens umzudrehen das war eine
goldrichtige entscheidung und christian
lindner den ich ja viele jahre kennen
ist auch genau der richtige mann gerade
in so einer schwierigen phase herzlichen
dank christian doerr das war das
richtige fragen spezial und damit gebe
ich wieder nach unten
[Musik]